[Musique]
bonsoir lundi 19 octobre bienvenue sur
tv soixante dix huit pour cette nouvelle
édition spéciale proposée par la
rédaction voici les titres le
département frappé par la folie
terroristes à conflans sainte honorine
samuel pâtit professeur d'histoire
géographie de 47 ans a été décapitée
vendredi près du collège du bois d'aulne
où il enseignait visé pour avoir montré
en classe des caricatures du prophète
mahomet lors d'un cours sur la liberté
d'expression
un hommage national aux leurres à aura
lieu mercredi et depuis cette attaque
qui a suscité une vive émotion à des
rassemblements se sont multipliées
invité dans cette édition
le député des yvelines d'idlib et cher
et la secrétaire du stress fsu dans les
yvelines delphine romani et puis l'autre
titres de l'actualité c'est la mise en
place du couvre feu en ile-de-france
depuis ce week-end des déplacements
strictement limité entre 21h et 6h du
matin pour freiner l'épidémie de kobe de
samedi les forces de l'ordre ont procédé
aux premiers contrôles sur le territoire
reportage à suivre également les
réactions yvelinoise à l'attentât de
conflans sainte honorine celle du
département des yvelines notamment qui
propose de rebaptiser l'établissement le
collège du bois d'aulne au nom de samuel
pâtit
les rassemblements et les hommages se
multiplient en la mémoire de samuel
pâtit cet enseignant
d'histoire-géographie assassiné vendredi
pour avoir montré des caricatures de
mahomet lors de son cours d'éducation
civique sur la liberté d'expression
et c'est devant l'établissement où a eu
lieu le drame le collège du bois donne à
conflans sainte honorine n'est qu'ils
sont venus en fraternité plusieurs
représentants de la communauté musulmane
dont l'imam de drancy hassen chalghoumi
se sont réunis devant le collège du bois
donne cet après midi trois jours après
la terrible attaque ils ont voulu
montrer qu'ils étaient solidaires et
qu'il condamnait fermement l'acte
barbare ils se sont recueillis et ont
prié également quelques minutes sur
place
astrid bergère et nicolas landry pour
les propos recueillis on a des valeurs
on a des lois en france qui protège les
musulmans et que presque tout le monde
contre le racisme il a un d autre
je pense que on a des associations aussi
comme l'écrit sos racisme qui veille sur
ça et qui sont un thermomètre on n'a pas
besoin de l'islamisme qui ne défend ni
de leur ca fournit des autres
malheureusement en même temps
l'amalgamme ya pas de fumée sans feu
si on ne réagit pas c'est eux c'est les
islamistes les fanatiques il nous a mis
dans ce gouffre là ils ont tué un autre
nom je pense que tout pour éviter l'
amalgame
il faut que la communauté axor a
s'exprime on a envie justement de crier
que non nous on est on est on est
français on est musulman effectivement
de religion mais on est français on
exactement comme samuel on a envie nous
aussi de pouvoir s'exprimer comme là je
suis en train de le faire
sans être obligé de regarder au derrière
moi ou autour de moi si je risque pas
quoi que ce soit et parmi les
représentants du culte musulman dans les
yvelines la réaction aussi dû à cames 78
le collectif des associations musulmanes
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et ses
environs il exprime dans un communiqué
son effroi suite aux crimes sauvages de
conflans sainte honorine et condamne
fermement cet acte
l'heure est à l'unité pour faire bloc
commun affirme le cam 78 qui reconnaît
en samuel pâtit un diffuseur de savoir
une personne qui luttait contre
l'ignorance et l'ignorance qui peut se
transformer déplore le collectif en
folie et meurtrière lorsqu on la laisse
nous diviser fin de citation et depuis
conflans sainte honorine on retrouve
tout de suite nicolas d'andry qui est
sur place nicolas d'andré de la
rédaction de tv 60,18 vous avez suivi le
rassemblement de plusieurs imams cet
après midi depuis le collège du bois
donne qui est devenu un depuis vendredi
un lieu de recueillement nicolas on aura
l'occasion de voir dans un instant un
reportage qui revient sur le week-end de
mobilisation sur place est-ce que des
anonymes des élus des professeurs des
élèves viennent encore ce surplace ce
soir nicolas effectivement grigoryan
l'heure est toujours aux caïmans 72
heures après les faits des parents des
familles des jeunes aussi un tout à
l'heure un jeune anciens élèves de ce
collège est venu se recueillir pour
rendre hommage à sa mue et le pâtis ce
professeur d'histoire et géographie de
47 ans enseignant dans l'établissement
derrière moi le collège le bois d'aulne
ils viennent déposer des fleurs des
dessins des messages pour défendre la
liberté la liberté d'expression demain
demain soir mardi 20 octobre à 18h30
aura lieu un départ d'une marche blanche
depuis le lieu où je me trouve
exactement devant ce collège
et puis ce sera avant donc le grand jour
le mercredi 21 octobre donc jours
d'hommage national à 19h à l'université
paris sorbonne
nicolas que c'est tout de l'anc est en
cours sur cette attaque perpétrée il ya
trois jours et bien grégory samuel
bhatti a été assassiné aux alentours de
17 heures vendredi 16 octobre alors
qu'il était sur le chemin du retour
entre son lieu de travail et son
domicile
l'assassin a été identifiée abattu par
la police il s'agirait da luz d'abdul
hack à individu d'origine tchétchène
résidant à evreux dans le département de
l'eure pour l'heure onze personnes sont
placées en garde à vue parmi elles des
proches du meurtrier mais aussi des
parents d'élèves qui s'opposaient à la
démarche du professeur de montrer ses
caricatures du prophète mahomet est
aussi une figure de l'islam radical
abdel hakim sefrioui qui est aussi fiché
s l'enquète devra déterminer comment
l'auteur des faits a pu identifier un
samuel pâtit et s'il a bénéficié de
complicités
par ailleurs parallèlement à cette
enquête d'après nos informations les
services de renseignement territoriaux
des yvelines devrait renforcer leur
mobilisation contre le l'islamisme
radical présent dans le département des
yvelines
merci nicolas landry pour ces précisions
depuis le collège du bois d'aulne à
conflans sainte honorine
c'est dans cet établissement vous l'avez
souligné nicolas qu'enseigner à samuel
pâti à proximité aussi de ce lieu et
qu'il a été assassiné depuis élèves
professeurs parents élus ou anonymes
sont venus se sont eux rassemblés aussi
spontanément et se sont recueillis
devant ce collège retour sur ce week-end
dommage avec eléonore sinoquet mélanie
poker avec aussi la collaboration des
deux jesse et willens de nos confrères
de radio sensations et bein je veux dire
ce soir à tous les enseignants de france
que nous sommes avec eux que la nation
toute entière sera là à leurs côtés
aujourd'hui et demain dès vendredi soir
le président de la république a rendu
hommage à samuel pâtit ce professeur
assassiné pour avoir enseigné la liberté
d'expression pendant tout le week end
des personnes connues ou anonymes se
sont également succédés sur le parvis du
collège le bois d'aulne de conflans
sainte honorine
samedi le maire s'est exprimé pour la
première fois depuis le drame
nous sommes ici à
conflans-sainte-honorine dans une ville
où il fait bon vivre
alors je dois dire aujourd'hui à mes
habitants que nous nous relèverons nous
nous relèverons tous ensemble parmi les
nombreuses personnes qui se sont
spontanément rassemblés le samedi des
collégiens qui avait samuel pâti comme
professeur dans cette haine non mais je
peux comprendre que ça puisse choquer
certains élèves qu'on représente leur
prophète parce que le prophète chez les
musulmans il ne doit pas être présenté à
la base mais on en france et la liberté
l'ubs la liberté le droit de l'acier
mais la liberté d'expression bah c'est
autorisé donc je vais dire ça n'aurait
jamais dû prendre autant d'ampleur
c'est un professeur d'histoire très
souriant très positifs tout le temps qui
mettait à l'aise dans son cours qui
parlait beaucoup à ses élèves qui
laissait la liberté d'expression à
chacun des élèves
face à cet acte de barbarie un mélange
de sentiments
deux jours après le drame le dimanche
colère tristesse et chocs étaient
toujours présents ça nous touche
énormément
c'est un drame incroyable quoi
épouvantable sûr on pense pas que ça
arrive chez nous tout près de chez nous
près des écoles de nos petits je suis
tellement totalement solidaire avec le
corps enseignant qui aujourd'hui veut
continuer à travailler à apporter le
savoir malgré toutes les peurs qui
doivent naître de cette horrible chose
c'est très important
la défense de la liberté témoignage en
faire cet homme que le bol courage
exercer son métier correctement comme
italie d'un signe et aux enfants ce qui
est vert enseigner
une marche blanche est organisée demain
mardi 20 octobre à conflans sainte
honorine un moyen de rendre un dernier
hommage locale avant la cérémonie
nationale de mercredi
des hommages ont eu lieu aussi partout
en france et dans les yvelines ces
images déjà à poissy ont un
rassemblement se tenait non ce n'est pas
le rassemblement à poissy mais un
rassemblement était prévu à poitiers à
17 heures avec des personnes qui sont
venues sur place mobilisation également
du côté de guyancourt devant la mairie
avec aussi une centaine de personnes
présentes sur place aussi l'hommage hier
à montigny-le-bretonneux un premier
rassemblement avait eu lieu ce dimanche
à l'initiative de procès professeurs
exerçant dans la commune ce lundi midi
c'était la municipalité de
montigny-le-bretonneux qui avait appelé
au recueillement plus d'une centaine de
personnes présentes ainsi que des
pompiers le maire laurin merker a
prononcé un discours avant de demander
de respecter une minute de silence
ponctué d'applaudissements spontanés
d'une marseillaise les propos recueillis
par mélanie poker je souhaitais aussi
que l'on puissent formaliser ce temps
cette minute de silence aujourd'hui pour
exprimer à la fois notre notre soutien
comme je le disais mais aussi notre
colère
comme j'ai pu le dire ça suffit il ne
doit plus laisser passer on doit plus
tolérer que les enseignants soient remis
en cause dans le renseignement qu'il
prodigue auprès de leurs élèves
toutes ces petites ces petits
arrangements ces petites tolérance que
l'on a pu avoir ces dernières années
envers certains qui pousse et qui
cherche tout le temps à bousculer notre
modèle eh bien il faut plus laisser
passer parce qu'on voit à quoi ça
conduit à quoi ça nous mène et d'autres
rassemblements sont prévus ce soir en
mairie de versailles à partir de 19
heures demain à magny les hameaux même
heure plaisir villepreux ou la verrière
ont prévu ces communes une mobilisation
mercredi un jour de l'hommage national
qui sera rendu à samuel pâti à la
sorbonne
parmi les hommages celui aussi du
département des yvelines la collectivité
qui a la compétence des collèges propose
de renommer le bois d'aulne du nom de
samuel patty est la proposition sera
soumise au vote lors du prochain conseil
d'administration de l'établissement
au retour des vacances de la toussaint
il faudra que la décision soit ensuite
actées en conseil municipal à conflans
sainte honorine avant d'être de lettres
en assemblée départementale
écoutez pierre bédier président du
département sur les raisons de cette
proposition il ya deux bonnes raisons à
cela d'abord parce que je peux enseigner
à une telle cruauté
alors que nec encore une fois que dans
la transmission dans la volonté de bien
faire dans la volonté d'aider les
enfants tout ça particulièrement
abominable donc ce qu'est ce que ça
mérite notre reconnaissance éternelle
comme on dit et puis d'autre part moi je
pense que c'est aussi une façon
d'exorciser ce qui s'est passé dans ces
collèges qui fera partie de l'histoire
de ce collège est plutôt que d'en faire
une douleur cacher ce dont nous sommes
une douleur constructive
une douleur qui affirme au vu et au su
de tout le monde
l'importance de la transmission de
l'enseignement et de ses plis la
république que sont la liberté
conscience la liberté de croyance la
liberté d'expression le conseil
départemental des yvelines qui a mis en
place une cellule d'écouté psychologique
elle est installée au secteur d'action
sociale de conflans sainte honorine 1
rue de pologne elle est ouverte de 10
heures
17h elle s'adresse aux témoins de
l'attentât et aux personnes en état de
choc joignable au numéro qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran deux autres cellules
sont ouvertes la première au collège du
bois d'aulne pour les collégiens leurs
familles et les professeurs elle sera
effective jusqu'à demain mardi soir et
puis par ailleurs une cellule
téléphonique est mise en place également
pour les personnes directement touchées
par le drame joignable au numéro de
téléphone qui s'affiche
deux invités sont désormais avec moi
tout d'abord en plateau didier baichère
bonsoir bonsoir député la république en
marge de la première circonscription des
yvelines et par visio défilent romani
bonsoir secrétaire départemental du snes
fsu dans les yvelines syndicats de
l'enseignement dans le second degré déjà
une réaction à cette actualité le
département des yvelines qui souhaitent
rebaptisé le nom de ce collège le
collège du bois d'aulne au nom du de
saluer le papier ce que c'est un bel
hommage pour pour ce professeur c'est un
hommage très certainement je pense que
ce sera là la communauté éducative
localement qui pourra qui pourrait le
décider mais c'est évidemment un très
très bel hommage
on est je crois tous sidérés bien sûr
sous le coup de l'émotion de cet acte de
barbarie et je pense qu'il faut par tous
les moyens à dresser notre notre
soutient la communauté éducative des
yvelines je voudrais aussi dire un
message pour les musulmans des yvelines
parce que je voudrais pas qu'ils
s'imaginent qu'à un moment donné on va
vouloir les stigmatiser à travers cette
cette affaire ce cet acte absolument
barbares ils sont eux mêmes victimes
ils sont victimes de l'islam politique
de l'islam radical et donc on est on est
tout à fait en capacité de ne pas tout
mélanger et je crois que on a cette
chance en france de pouvoir croire ou ne
pas croire et c'est justement parce
qu'on peut croire ou ne pas croire qu'on
respecte l'ensemble de nos religions des
religions qui sont présentes en france
maintenant il faut aussi bien comprendre
que la religion elle reste à la porte du
travail elle reste à la porte de l'école
pour que chacun puisse enseigner la
laïcité la liberté d'expression et cette
liberté de croire ou ne pas croire
elle file remaniée sur cette proposition
de renommer le collège du bois d'aulne
au nom de samuel pâtit pas ce que vous
en pensez
oui tout à fait je rejoins tout à fait
le point de vue de notre intervenant
c'est effectivement un bel hommage mais
c'est à la communauté éducative de
l'établissement aux élèves
aux enseignants aux parents d'élèves
bien sûr de se prononcer je pense que
c'est certainement ce qui se fera à la
rentrée
et effectivement nous aussi à ça fait
suer évidemment on partage on s'associe
à la peine des enseignants des élèves
des familles on est profondément
bouleversé en tant qu'enseignant de de
ce drame affreux et on exprime notre
soutien à toutes les personnes qui ont
pu être touchés par ce drame at les
sentiments et y règne ce soir parmi les
professeurs delphine romani eh bien je
les jeux les dix ans ils sont à la fois
sur le choc est à la fois je crois que
le message qu'on a envie de faire passer
c'est que les enseignants sont
profondément attachés à la liberté
d'expression au fait que l'école est un
lieu dont la mention pardon la mission
fondamentale est d'enseigner la liberté
d'expression d'inviter les élèves à
débattre à mettre à distance les choses
de manière critique
c'est ça que nous défendons c'est une
mission fondamentale de l'école est
aujourd'hui c'est évidemment le choeur
de l'école qui attaque et alex plusieurs
contre offensive du gouvernement après
un conseil de défense
hier soir à l'élysée déjà ça a été
annoncé ce matin alors gérald darmanin
le ministre de l'intérieur des
opérations de police en cours 50 et une
association contrôler plusieurs avant
être dissoute l'expulsion aussi de deux
cent trente et une personnes étrangères
fiesch vs la question aussi que l'on
peut se poser après ce conseil de
défense et comment davantage protéger
les professeurs didier baichère comment
on peut les protéger davantage
je pense qu'il faut libérer la parole de
manière importante des studios je crois
qu'il ya déjà aujourd'hui des lignes d
coûte des moyens de parler avec sa
hiérarchie mais porter plainte c'est
parfois compliqué il faut aussi
ressentir on est dans un environnement
où on peut porter plainte et on peut
parler de ce sujet là et je crois que ce
qui a fait défaut probablement ses
dernières années c'est de libérer cette
parole est de laisser s'insinuer que
peut-être la religion musulmane l'islam
politique pousse à se mélanger
énormément et qu'on avait un peu de mal
à en parler moi je vois un des effets
donc en 2018 quand on a passé la loi sur
la sécurité intérieure qui permet
aujourd'hui on le voit depuis depuis
vendredi soir de pouvoir faire ces
perquisitions administratives auprès
d'associations qu'on peut suspecter un
moment donné d'avoir des pratiques
d'islam radical donc il ya des éléments
qui existe je pense qu'il faut
maintenant les affirmer avec force et
que chacun se sente libre mais aussi
encore une fois je pense de comprendre
la situation
si des parents à un moment donné on plus
mélanger leur propre religion et ce qui
est enseigné à l'école c'est qu'il ya un
vrai problème est là on est dans un
problème de compréhension de ce qu'est
la laïcité
encore une fois ce qui est la force de
croire ou ne pas croire la croyance elle
s'arrête à la porte de l'école et nous
on enseigne la laïcité et la liberté
d'expression en france et ça c'est
extrêmement important
je vous fait réagir delphine roumanie à
votre avis comment davantage protéger
ses professeurs on sait que samuel pâtit
avait été au coeur voilà d'une polémique
il y avait aussi voilà eu plusieurs
pressions de parents d'élèves
peut-être manqué t-il une protection
policière comment comment faut-il et
protéger davantage ses professeurs alors
oui je crois que l'effective mans en
termes de protection policière le
ministère de l'intérieur a un rôle à
jouer en effet pour assurer la
protection physique des personnes je
crois aussi que le point de départ de
cette histoire c'est un problème
pédagogique et qu'il ya beaucoup
possible à faire pour outiller les
professeurs pour les aider à mieux
aborder toutes ces questions qui c'est
vrai sont des questions sensibles mais à
la fois sur des questions essentielles
et qui doivent qui doivent être abordés
en classe et je crois qu'il ya aussi
effectivement beaucoup de travail à
faire dans le cadre de l'institution
scolaire pour permettre aux professeurs
d'être pleinement équipés pour aborder
toutes les questions qui sont complexes
réguler davantage peut-être aussi parce
que je voudrais pas que les enseignants
les professeurs la communauté éducative
et l'impression que ils doivent assumer
seuls cette responsabilité de la
formation à la liberté d'expression à la
laïcité c'est un sujet qui est beaucoup
plus vaste
on le voit dans le domaine du sport les
associations les éducateurs les
animateurs donc je moi j'ai appelé dès
vendredi soir à la tenue d'assises de la
république des états généraux de la
république pour que en fait les
collectivités territoriales les
associations les animateurs les
éducateurs du département puissent
travailler ensemble pour définir comment
on va porter ce message sur la laïcité
ça peut pas être les enseignants seul au
moment de de la période scolaire qui
peuvent porter ce message il doit être
porté dans le sport dans les clubs de
sport dans l'école au moment de la
culture moment de toutes les activités
des jeunes pendant leur scolarité
réguler aussi davantage peut-être les
réseaux sociaux on sait qu'il est député
laetitia via qui a porté un texte de loi
sur la haine en ligne qui a été censuré
en juin elle prépare d'ailleurs une
nouvelle mouture il faut travailler
davantage sur sur cette question de la
haine en ligne c'est indispensable
aujourd'hui on est face à des acteurs
qui sont des géants industriels on parle
de facebook de twitter d'instagram donc
on est on n'a pas affaire à des amateurs
donc c'est ce sont des entreprises qui
ont énormément de moyens et dans le
texte de la proposition de loi de deux
ma collègue laetitia vient il est
effectivement question d'une meilleure
régulation de pouvoir retirer sous 24
heures
les contenus haineux et donc si la loi
avait été passé cela n'a pas été
censurée par le conseil constitutionnel
il y aurait pu y avoir par exemple dans
le cas de la vidéo des parents
de cette jeune fille qui était dans
cette classe la vidéo aurait pu être
retiré immédiatement après sa diffusion
le conseil constitutionnel ayant censuré
il faut reprendre le travail
effectivement je pense que dans la
future loi sur la le renforcement de la
licité on pourra remettre des éléments
il ya un travail aussi qui est emploi
qui est important c'est un dialogue au
niveau européen ce que la france ne veut
pas tout seul porter ces sujets de
luttre contre la haine sur internet et
je sais que nous travaillons et qui aura
probablement un texte commun au niveau
européen sur ces sujets là qui va être
proposé dans les jours qui viennent je
voulais profiter de votre présence
didier baichère je vous redonne la
parole dans un instant delphine roumanie
pour parler aussi d'une polémique alors
qui a été relayée pas mal par le
rassemblement national notamment ce
week-end sur des propos tenus par votre
consoeur député michel devaux couleurs
qui a député de la 7e circonscription
des yvelines concernant samuel pâtit
elle a qualifié de mauvaise idée le fait
de demander aux élèves musulmans s'ils
voulaient quitter la classe au moment de
montrer à les caricaturer le répondait
d'ailleurs à chaud à des questions de
nos confrères de m6 écoutez là elle
regrette en cette polémique et des
propos mal interprétés sortis de leur
contexte je regrette que ces coraux a
été mal interprétés ils ont été mal
interprétés parce qu'ils ont été sortis
de leur contexte je répondais une
question qui était qu'est ce que vous
savez de ce qui a pu se passer dans les
jours précédents et donc si on regarde
le propos par rapport à cette question
la dimension qui n'aurait jamais dû
cesser d'avoir cette dit que j'étais sur
un exposé factuelle de ce que je
connaissais de la situation bien
évidemment à aucun moment il ya un
jugement de ma part sur la liberté
danser mieux dans ce mythe ce professeur
et le droit légitime et même
l'obligation d'enseigner cette liberté
d'expression je le regrette je le
regrette vivement
effectivement je je regrette d'avoir eu
cette d'avoir tout simplement répondu à
ce média
passage puisque voilà on s'est attaché à
une phrase qui était vraiment déconnecté
des connective nous parle de quad une
polémique inutile ou est ce qu'on peut
dire quand même que les mots de
mauvaises idées n'étaient pas forcément
les plus appropriées c'était un moment
qui était compliqué un vendredi pour
avoir suivi ça de près dé quasiment
17h30 18h voilà il ya je pense qu'avec
des motions importante et la polémique
n'est pas utile maintenant pour pour
ceux qui nous écoutent c'est aussi
important de ne pas laisser penser que
les enseignants ne pourrait faire un
cours un peu comme bon leur semble etc
on est dans une institution qui est
extrêmement contrôlé les programmes font
l'objet de débats réguliers via un
conseil pédagogique qui est en place et
qui fait que l'enseignant répond à un
programme et une manières d'enseigner
les sujets en fonction d'un cadrage
national qui est partagé par l'ensemble
des professeurs donc c'est l'initiative
individuelle n'existe pas à l'éducation
nationale dans ce type de sujet donc ne
laissons pas penser que peut-être on
aurait un enseignant qui aurait
outrepassé sa manière d'enseigner ou ses
fonctions je sais pas on est sûr que non
une autre polémique qui a pris de
l'ampleur
tout au long du week-end c'est
l'académie de versailles en la personne
de sa rectrice charline à venelles qui
s'est vu reprocher de possibles
sanctions à l'encontre de samuel pâtit
ont fait le point avec vous et mélanie
poquet bonsoir on ça tous parlent d'un
article
c'est ça du point nos confrères
rapportent cette phrase l'inspection
académique a contacté le parent d'élève
et lui a exprimé son étonnement et le
fait qu'ils allaient sévir un extrait
rapidement repris par des médias comme
valeurs actuelles et des cadres du
rassemblement national
mais c'est une phrase prononcée par adel
hakim ses fruits
militant islamiste aujourd'hui placé en
garde à vue la rectrice et la rectrice
et très vite visées sur les réseaux
sociaux selon une plateforme de veille
médiatique près de 5500 tweet évoque le
nombre de chars ni la venelle en 24
heures hier en fin de journée l'académie
de versailles fait un communiqué de
presse
les informations sont qualifiés de
fallacieuses à aucun moment il n'a été
dit ni même sous-entendu ni penser que
l'institution allait sévir contre
monsieur pâtissons ce communiqué
l'académie de versailles fait aussi le
point sur le déroulé des derniers jours
le 5 octobre dernier samuel pâtit
professeur d'histoire-géo donne un cours
sur la liberté d'expression avec
notamment pour supports des caricatures
de mahomet
et le cours déclenché des réactions de
parents d'élèves l'académie mobilise
l'équipe valeurs de la république
ce sont des référents intervenant au cas
par cas dans des situations relevant de
la pédagogie de la laïcité dans le
traitement de contestation d'élèves de
comportement inadéquat
un père de famille a ensuite rencontré
le chef d'établissement accompagné
d'abdelhakim ses fruits qui se serait
présenté comme un représentant des imams
de france
le père de famille interpelle alors
l'inspection académique il rencontre
c'est à la suite de ces rencontres que
de vidéos sont mises en ligne des vidéos
au de ce père de famille qui diffuse des
fausses informations et un strong on
instrumentalise les faits pour
l'académie c'est surtout dans ces vidéos
que le nom et l'établissement de samuel
pâtissons donner une plainte a été
déposée par le professeur et par
l'éducation nationale qui s'est mise en
relation avec les services de police
l'académie conclu en annonçant qu'une
enquête de l'inspection générale a été
demandée merci mélanie pour ces
précisions delphine romani qui est
toujours avec nous en ligne secrétaire
du snes fsu des yvelines déjà pour faire
réagir sur cette polémique est ce que
vous avez le sentiment aujourd'hui
d'être assez protégé les professeurs par
votre hiérarchie
oui je crois que vraiment je partais ce
que dit à votre votre intervenants le
temps je crois n'est pas à la polémique
nous ce qu'on souhaite c'est avant tout
condamné cet acte effroyable
il ya beaucoup d'informations qui
circulent c'est là sur les réseaux
sociaux qui ont circulé avant le drame
mais qui circulent actuellement
nous on appelle la prudence à la retenue
sur toutes ces questions il faut aussi
respecter le travail d'enquêté qui est
en cours et qui dira si effectivement il
y a eu il ya eu des problèmes des
difficultés des choses qui n'ont pas été
traités comme comme elle l'aurait dû et
pour l'instant je crois que vraiment
nous ce qu'on souhaite c'est respecter
le deuil de toutes les familles partager
leur peine et surtout ne pas rentrer
dans des polémiques inutiles mais est ce
que cette situation à laquelle a dû
faire face samuel pâtit avant cet
assassinat celle de subir des pressions
ensuite à un cours qui l'a donnée est ce
que c'est récurrent pour les professeurs
et ce qu'ils subissent régulièrement des
pressions de la part des parents
d'élèves notamment
eh bien écoutez je crois que non c'est
pas quelque chose qui arrive de manière
courante non un syndicat on est dans
notre rôle on s'est tourné vers
l'institution pour que toutes les
dispositions soient prises pour que les
personnels les élèves les familles
souhaitent écouter etc c'est
fondamentalement ce que nous des soins
dans le quotidien ce que nous souhaitons
est ce qu'il ya quelque chose
aujourd'hui que vous demandez alors
profité de la présence de didier
baichère en plateau député de la
première circonscription des yvelines
que vous demander au gouvernement et à
la majorité présidentielle
aujourd'hui alors ce qu'on va demander à
l'institution d'une partie qu'elle
continue avec côté à protéger entendant
les personnels je pense que à la rentrée
le 2 novembre viendra le temps
d'accueillir de nouveau les élèves dans
les établissements
donc ce qu'on leur demande c'est
effectivement de nous écouter de nous
concerter préparer au mieux cette
rentrée est de faire en sorte qu' aucun
enseignant ne se trouve en difficulté
face à la lourde tâche qui va être la
nôtre quand nous devrons de nouveau
faire face à nos élèves d'animaux avec
vous didier baichère oui la priorité est
ce que c'est la rentrée une autre
question est ce que ça justifie d'autant
plus la prise de parole ya quelques
semaines de d'emmanuel macron sur la
présentation de ce plan contre les
séparatismes là ça nécessite d'autant
plus de lancer très rapidement ce projet
de loi rapidement oui mais c'est vrai
qu'on était dans ce contexte avec le
procès de charlie hebdo qui fait qu'on
savait que la menace terroriste
elle était importante maintenant je vois
personne encore une fois peut imaginer
que la barbarie allait être celle celle
que nous avons vécue je pense qu'il y
aura un travail à faire et l'éducation
nationale va aider et déjà sur le sujet
pour qu'à la rentrée une expression
importante dans chacune des classes au
collège au lycée pour que les élèves
puissent aussi verbaliser ce qui s'est
passé et qu'on puisse reparler de la
liberté d'expression
et puis moi j'espère que ce texte
nouveau sur le renforcement de la
laïcité permettra aussi de punir
l'ensemble des protagonistes de cette
affaire parce que vous l'avez très bien
dit à plusieurs reprises les réseaux
sociaux deviennent très vite des
tribunaux et pour avoir vu les vidéos en
question avant qu'elle soit retirée de
youtube
il y avait vraiment un appel à l'un chez
cette personne et ça n'est pas possible
ce n'est pas comme ça que ça fonctionne
en france on voit aussi que le débat
religieux s'est installé dans les cours
d'école ça n'est pas possible donc je
pense qu'il faut apporter une nouvelle
vigilance à ces sujets là et sévir de
manière très très forte
merci à d'abord être avec nous à didier
baichère député de la première
circonscription des yvelines et merci à
des films roumanie qui était en ligne
avec mon physio mais revient pour bonne
soirée à tous vos jolies tard merci
secrétaire départemental du snes fsu
dans les yvelines et depuis l'assassinât
de samuel pâtit les réactions de la
classe politique se multiplient tous
condamnent unanimement la mort de
l'enseignant tué pour avoir fait son
métier les propos qui ont été collectés
recueillis par sediag à 200 go est un
des premiers hommes politiques à réagir
et le sénateur l ère des yvelines et
président du sénat gérard larcher sur
son compte twitter assassiné pour avoir
enseigné la liberté de penser d'écrire
de caricaturer assassiné pour avoir
enseigné que nous sommes une société de
liberté qui refuse le fanatisme et la
haine
je pense à la communauté enseignante et
à ses proches ne reculons plus ce matin
lundi 19 octobre dans le cadre de
l'ouverture du congrès des régions de
france dans l'hémicycle du conseil
régional de saint-ouen valérie pécresse
présidente de la région ile de france a
voulu rendre hommage à l'enseignant je
ne puis débuté notre séance sans
partager avec vous l'horreur que nous
inspire l'assassinât barbare du
professeur samuel pâtit samuel patty a
été égorgé par un terroriste islamiste
dans notre belle région d'île de france
à conflans sainte honorine il habitait
errani il enseignait l'histoire
géographie et c'était un homme de bien
le maire génération de trappes ali
rabais a déclaré également dans un tweet
j'ai juste la nausée pensée pour les
proches et les collègues de la victime
et pour finir dans un communiqué de
presse publié samedi 10
octobre le rassemblement national des
yvelines apporte son soutien à
l'ensemble du corps enseignant et
s'attaquent à certains élus du
département la fédération des yvelines
du rassemblement national appelle les
yvelinois a cessé d'accorder leur
confiance à ceux qui depuis des années
met en oeuvre des politiques
clientélistes et immigrationniste qui
favorise le communautarisme et le
séparatisme terreau du terrorisme
fin de citation et puis ces images
celles de sept minutes
d'applaudissements hier lors du 5e tour
de coupe de france entre conflans sainte
honorine et aulnay sous bois cinquième
tour qui se jouait hier dimanche les
conflanais se sont qualifiés à l'issue
des tirs au but mickaël ennemi doro
reviendra sur cette performance dans son
émission 7 8 sport à 18h30 sur tv 78
voilà ce que l'on pouvait vous dire
trois jours après l'assassinât de samuel
papier je vous rappelle un hommage
national est prévue ce mercredi à la
sorbonne en hommage à cet enseignant
assassiné
et l'autre titres de l'actualité c'est
bien sûr la mise en place du couvre feu
depuis ce week-end dans les yvelines
pour faire face à la recrudescence de
l'épidémie de coronavirus de 21h à 6h du
matin sauf dérogation il est désormais
interdit de se trouver sur la voie
publique samedi pour la première soirée
de couvre-feu yvelinoise à yvelinois ont
dû s'organiser pour être rentrés chez
eux avant 21h des contrôles de police
ont ensuite été organisées
michael almy droit suivi la soirée il
est 20 heures ici à montigny le
bretonneux le stress se fait ressentir
la proche du couvre-feu vélo bus
voitures chacun s'organise pour rentrer
chez soi avant 21h un tout petit peu
stressé à cause du couvre-feu on doit
tous être chez nous à ranteil north à ne
jamais oublier qu'on a des seins travail
en interne avec des heures de sport
du coup la journée c'est compliqué de
finir sa journée à 21h faut vraiment
être à une heure chez soi et si bas on
dépasse de quelques minutes on peut se
faire prendre
mais en soif c'est quand même une bonne
chose par rapport à un virus qui circule
parce que on sait quand même que la
contamination se fait dans les soirées
étudiantes surtout depuis ce matin on
suivra ce soir il faut rentrer à 21h
c'est compliqué voilà faut s'organiser
compliqué parmi les personnes touchées
par le couvre-feu les restaurateurs ici
chez ceux qui bavent dernier repas à
20h30 avant le baisser de rideau à une
centaine de mètres même constat dans cet
établissement de montigny le bretonneux
si d'ordinaire le samedi soir la
structure fait entre 40 et 50 couverts
ce premier samedi de couvre-feu
seulement une dizaine ont été servis on
va essayer quand même
développer un peu l'emporter comme on
l'a fait
ailleurs sur notre restaurant de
chavenay et mais malheureusement on sait
pas si les gens ne viennent pas on on
dépend d'eux des clients et s'il n'y a
pas de clients pas de chiffre d'affaires
il est elle désormais à 21h le couvre
feu a débuté il y à quelques instants
comme vous pouvez le voir derrière moi
les yvelinois jouent le jeu et les rues
sont désertes
on croise seulement des voitures sur la
route patrouille de voie publique et
opérations de contrôles se sont
organisés objectif vérifiés les
attestations de dérogation elles
permettent de circuler dans l'espace
public entre 21h et 6h du matin pour des
motifs impérieux de famille pour des
motifs de santé pour du soin animale
notamment donc en fait on est en train
de vérifier que chaque personne et son
attestation à partir du moment où vous
avez une mesure aussi importante que le
couvre-feu qui est mise en place qui a
des raisons sanitaires majeurs et qu'il
est important nécessaire de montrer à la
population que des contrôles sont
effectués pour que le civisme soit
constatée et là ce soir nous le
constatons avec enthousiasme le non
respect du couvre feu entrait une
contravention de 135 euros des nouvelles
mesures plutôt bien appliquée dans le
département mais voilà c'est la fin de
cette édition spéciale merci de votre
fidélité belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]